welcome back to another episode of
chappelle's world my guest today
miss cat teen yeah there we go pet team
lee
no that is um
a different vietnamese last name though
i will say oh like i don't have anything
like no and that's actually my uh actual
legal name because a lot of vietnamese
people when they came here they have a
vietnamese name then they have american
name that they give to people at school
or work
mine is technically
uh l.e wait yours is technically what uh
l-e no no oh my work name my american
name is cat now
oh i never really had one because
everyone always called me cat teen and
that's fine and then i started working
at the podcast and i remember brendan
giving me the nickname cat and it just
kind of stuck
it's so funny that all these years of
you being
alive
he's the first person to give you cat
yeah right that's everything
everyone calls me uh teen back at home
so it's kind of cool that's that's
actually dope now wait are we saying it
right as americans is it caten
that's the english pronunciation that i
had come up with so yes it to my
standard yeah it is okay how do you say
that the vietnamese uh
translation would be cacti
yeah i'll try it
later you're doing great
thanks for having me no no thanks for
coming listen
oh wait yeah you're the
wow you popped the female cherry am i
you are the first am i the first
is that is that how i should say it is
that or you know i don't want to get i
think i think it's fine but it is like
that
it's a specific word choice
casey is it okay yeah
casey doesn't edit out anything i
promise i won't come out about anything
like cherries get popped
i'm just digging a hole i'm making a
hole
i'm digging a deep hole and i was trying
to i was like jerry's yeah you know what
you ever tried to tie uh uh
you know what i was like well
i couldn't get it out you're trying to
try to you were trying to try
i think i always watched people because
back in the day in like middle school
high school people always said like oh
that means you're good at making that
means you're good at making it it was
always more like a flirtatious like
first year someone would do to let you
know that they were good at something
and the other one was if you could open
a starburst yeah that was that was you
guys because we're so far apart in age
i am 20 26 i am turning 27 this year
i've known you for three years now yeah
it's been a hot minute oh wow that's
that's awesome yeah so yeah you're
turning 27 i'm 35 so that's
um
that's eight years eight years i know
because you're a year younger than
stevie okay yeah so that's eight yeah
we're eight years apart
but
i feel like
you know well because i guess being in
the cheerleading world and being like an
all-star competitive cheerleading like i
was just a round girl so like even like
but
i don't know like um but you know we
know we still know a lot of the same
stuff
yeah like you're pretty you're pretty up
to date i feel like you and i aren't
like a generation apart we kind of have
like a nice little like mix yeah yeah
like an in-betweener yeah i get a lot of
your references you get a lot of mine
uh-huh but you still are like older than
me yeah where the [ __ ] does that come
from are you just around like um i think
we have
more similar interests than we thought
we had with music because i'm really
into like
all emo like sad yeah [ __ ] yeah that's
sad girl um real sad girl real sad girl
[ __ ] yeah you're into the like rock punk
world i think we just kind of have that
connection but like when i when i okay
so this is why
when i think about when i cheered
and the girls i was around
like
and i'm not saying like you you're a
cheerleader but you fit like
they're emotional even though like
you're the age difference is like they
you know they're around my age yeah but
like
i i think i connect with you because you
remind me of girls that i cheered with
and why is that because that's in a good
way i used to dance in high school
that's why like i asked like what is
like what i don't know about it
what it is
you know some of the girls i cheer with
i [ __ ] hate it yeah listen everyone's
like oh my god she's so hot why don't
you try to holler at her i go cause
she's a [ __ ] [ __ ] all right i
don't like her like it's weird that like
because most guys can't say that you
know when they see like a hot girl or
something like that like they're like
all like giddy over and i'm like but
i've been around girls in a way to where
like i've like gotten to know them on
such like a personal level to where i'm
like yo that person really
yeah for a man
a woman out for being an [ __ ] i know
you've been around women long enough
exactly because i feel like most guys
who aren't around women don't have the
balls to kind of say it because you come
off as an [ __ ] yeah but but like i
say it in a way because it's like
you know like i'm not trying to be an
[ __ ] because i guess i mean i'm nice
to everybody but
there's times like man i mean man one
girl made me punch a [ __ ] brick wall
she made me so goddamn mad what happened
uh what did she do
oh
see it's so funny whenever i get angry
about the [ __ ] that i get angry i always
forget what it was but then i remember
so she was like the pretty girl on the
team yeah whatever and she kind of like
got everything you know a little bit she
had like an error about her where she's
used to getting her way yeah yeah yeah
and one day she came up and she just
started using my my computer
and said you
you can't use that yeah i was like wait
why you didn't even ask me and she was
like what i'm just using it i'm like
that's funny i was like how about you
get the [ __ ] off my computer you know
like you're not just going to [ __ ]
you know just use it without asking like
yeah like i wouldn't care if you use it
but i would just want you to ask and
then we got like a back and forth about
like because she was just like there's
nothing wrong with me just like i'm like
no you can't just roll up and use my i
don't give a [ __ ] how beautiful you are
now i remember i [ __ ] punched the
brick wall because i was so [ __ ] mad
just because like of the back and forth
but that's what it was was this your
wild turkey days
yes god was i drunk at the at that
moment yeah
maybe it might have been it might have
been but
back to what i was saying you remind me
the girls that i cheer with but like
because like i feel like we're actually
like dope friends like i feel like
talking to you is like actually dope
it's like you know like i feel like a
dope connection like you know i love
talking like all the music stuff with
you because you there's another side you
know i haven't gotten to talk about this
yet
i love a lot of girl groups
i love a lot of female artists mm-hmm
and i'll start off with one that i
really like
one you know i think i have a feeling
who it is i think you might know
who she is a little late and whenever i
mention this name casey i better have a
picture of her
pop right up
jojo jojo man
[Laughter]
he was gonna look bette midler up and
hocus pocus like i've got a spell on you
erica
because to be fair like bette midler is
casey's person you know is that yeah
that's his life he was just like oh [ __ ]
he's probably thinking yeah
yeah
was that her joint oh yeah that was
bette midler's joint
i remember that but yeah i love uh jojo
because i remember when i heard her
um it was around the time in high school
yeah and she had that baby it's you and
i was like yeah this is really cool
she's amazing so then within like
i think it was her second album where i
was like damn she's like really good
because sometimes like yeah when you
most people can't follow up
like a big yeah sophomore albums are
really really hard to
kind of like follow up your first one
especially if you're a artist that kind
of blew up that first time around
sophomore albums are kind of like yeah
of course
but she was like but like her talent is
so damn good where you're like damn
she's co-signed by whitney houston
she was and most people don't people
don't know that
people don't [ __ ] know that whitney
houston the queen herself
jojo she totally [ __ ] up she was stuck
in such a terrible predicament that just
hindered her career for so long thank
god for streaming because i don't think
she'd have a oh yeah
because
obviously before streaming she was just
stuck yeah and then once streaming came
she was able to like i mean she wasn't
able to make like an album but she was
able to like [ __ ]
you know uh at least do mixtapes or like
you know she was one of the first people
uh to my knowledge who started
re-recording her hits
when streaming came out because she went
back and re-recorded a lot of her
the first two albums first two albums
because at this point in time i think it
was 2014
streaming services had become huge and
someone came up with the idea like hey
maybe you can re-record all of them and
it was such a foreign idea back then
yeah she was kind of one of the first
people to do it i think taylor swift was
the first taylor swift no joe swift did
it recently right she did who was the
first to re-record well
was she
i thought it was i thought it was taylor
swift that was first definitely is the
biggest one as of right now just because
she re-recorded her
i believe it was the red album and she
came out with like a 10 minute diss
track to jake gyllenhaal that blew up oh
yeah everybody's been going off on that
what happened yeah okay so come on
the inside i love taylor swift i loved
her since
days okay yeah she was like country
taylor swift uh the song i like by her
is uh tim mcgraw
my guitar
how'd you know i i'm telling you i'm a
swifty i love taylor swift how did you
know that was a song i would like though
because that's a [ __ ] banger and i
know you know quality he's the reason
for this
i love it it's so i mean i know t swift
when i when it comes to the singing but
you guys get the idea you also have that
did you not like that song i just i know
wow
see that's what i'm saying i knew i
[ __ ] you cat i knew i [ __ ] with you
but taylor swift had uh re-recorded an
album that was bought out by scooter
braun cause um she used to be uh
represented by a
big red truck in some like small smaller
record label in nashville that had then
sold
to scooter braun he bought that company
yeah
justin bieber's man justin bieber uh
demi lovato ariana grande a lot of
really big names he did kid leroy for a
little bit but
ended up leaving
but
uh he bought that record label then
acquired her masters through that
purchase and
she was never given the ability to buy
her master's like to my knowledge
everyone who
has a record deal
basically
has the opportunity at some point later
in their career to buy their masters
back after a certain amount of time and
because scooter braun had bought uh the
record label he wasn't he didn't give
her the option to buy out her masters
and so she was really pissed about this
they had beef back and forth and she
said you know what i'm gonna re-record
he thought it was a bluff so he ended up
selling her catalog
to someone else and that company who
bought it said are you sure like she's
she says she's gonna re-record like why
should we spend all this money on buying
something that she's gonna just
re-record at this point
there really wasn't a precedent for
a successful re-recording of an album so
he said you know what even if she does
record i don't think it's going to be a
big deal like no one's going to go and
buy something that they already
have so it didn't sell
so it did end up selling because he's
like i don't i also don't think she's
going to re-record like let's call her
bluff on it so he sold it the company
bought it and what he doesn't know is my
girl taylor swift is the pettiest [ __ ]
out here it has a fantastic she has a
fan base unlike anyone else
the swifties the bars the beehive uh
bts's navy that's what i'm saying
because like that's what a lot of people
don't realize like in uh
like people that are managers or agents
or anything like that like the fans
don't know who they are yes you know
what i mean they don't give a [ __ ] they
don't give a [ __ ] because they like
taylor swift yes so taylor swift's like
yo don't [ __ ] with that album i'm
re-recording it mm-hmm dude uh [ __ ] with
this [ __ ] is that what she did yeah and
she got that album her fans got that
album that re-recorded album to number
one on the charts went in are you
serious yeah it beat out the records
when it first premiered when she first
sold the original red album gosh which
is insane where's this cover how do you
know all this [ __ ] what's something
because i'm telling you i love taylor
swift and i love i remember telling you
always have since elementary school
because she probably popped when you
were in elementary yeah i think i had
heard about her for the first time in
middle school because my cousin my older
cousin who used to babysit me really
often i really stole her entire playlist
i listened to all the music she did
because she was the one with the
computer who had itunes all the music i
had and my ipod were from her playlist
and she loved taylor swift because she
was
uh living in i want to say georgia or
south carolina at the time so she was
really into country music and she found
this teenage girl taylor swift who was
making love songs on my space so
would you because you i brought a
country i didn't mean to cut you off i
thought about because you said country
music because her earlier stuff
was [ __ ] straight up country now it's
just like transition to like now it's
full out but it's but like the thing is
it's like she was still killing it
country yeah but she was still [ __ ]
massive absolutely and like i guess what
she does now just took it to another
[ __ ]
uh level you know a lot of the reason
why she transitioned over to pop is
because she got a lot of flack in the
country world
like she was kind of yeah for a while
she was shunned by the uh
music industry within like the country
genre a lot of people didn't was it
or something yeah they considered it too
popular
a lot of country now it's like yeah like
florida line yeah florida georgia line
yeah [ __ ] uh
rascal flies
yeah yeah well just to give off some
like those are pretty [ __ ] poppy yeah
you know that's with shania twain shania
twain yes you know what i mean like
dolly parton yeah slappers you know
yeah all that's all that stuff's like
pretty poppy too like when when you hear
her stuff it's like fair it's all fair
yeah you know country music i would
assume
you know i mean i'm no like connoisseur
when it comes to the [ __ ]
country music world but i at least think
that like
she's got [ __ ] some type of notoriety
to be able to keep up with it yeah she's
like uh and she currently lives in
nashville i think she was from
pennsylvania or something originally and
then moved to nashville to pursue music
that's where she got her big break she
was singing in like these local bars and
stuff they [ __ ] with country in
pennsylvania uh i don't know
i think so she did at the very least
that's where she's from yeah what's
ready
wow
damn
where does this taste yeah people ask me
all the time how i know like little
things like this
like in depth you wonder why you this
that's why i [ __ ] with you and i knew it
because i'm deep dive lazy yeah okay i
like usually do a lot of deep diving or
whatever blah blah blah and uh
you know it's funny that you bring up
taylor swift because like
you know people think about like her
relationships and stuff like that and
uh
you know the one i i guess the one i
knew the most
well it wasn't even that long i think it
was her and john mayer oh yeah she has a
great song about him called dear john
really yeah that's about john mayer yeah
i should have known it's good it's deep
down lately [ __ ] that one up but also i
don't do too many deep dives on
t swift but i got but i really liked the
song
it was on one of
john mayer's albums oh yeah they made a
song together
and then they started dating i forgot
what it is
and she's not even in towards like to
like the end of the song she only does
like a small part yeah but uh you know i
don't know i think she's very talented
and i was like [ __ ] with her but like so
is that would that be your [ __ ]
number one uh my number one
i don't think so i think my number one
forever and always will be
william oh sorry um
close do i [ __ ] with jojo love her
love her
but
you know what i mean and i was
i fumbled it yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i
would say you fumbled it because i yeah
you know we should have been like right
there but wait who haley williams
apparently i'm trying to
if i died today what i want to hear when
like
i'm
entering heaven is like her voice really
that's what i want to hear okay she is
the
like her voice has kind of
like been burned in my brain as a
like
safety blanket yeah because i remember
back in the day this was when i was in
middle school when there were still
advertisements on tv for albums and cds
misery business was playing as like an
ad and i just remembered the hook like
uh
i never meant to brag but i got them
where i want them and now yeah and they
just kept playing that song and i was
never able to
like figure out what band it was because
it was in a like cd mix of other songs
oh kind of like one of those like now
yeah like now now yeah yeah but this one
was like for all rock
and i had found it later on myspace
because a girl i went to school with how
to ask her myspace like song on her
profile and i became obsessed with
paramore they were the very first band i
went to go actually concert in general
that i went to go see that was the first
one yeah and because i have very strict
parents i was not allowed to do anything
and when i was
19 i went to a paramore fall out boy
concert because they were headed that's
[ __ ] massive
and the tour was monumentor i drove all
the way from san jose to concord with my
friend and my younger sister i was going
through like a weird breakup at that
time
and i remember going there and having
such a cathartic experience yeah i felt
like it healed me from this breakup
i like i felt it and i never had felt
the sensation in my life of like i feel
healed yeah now because i realized we
are never ever ever
getting back together okay christian
you know that song yeah
this is what i love
and this is why i listen like [ __ ] with
a lot of like female artists
you know because
i think you know i love
when a female artist makes other females
feel good yeah because i know what like
oasis like makes me feel
you know as a as an individual and as a
as a man
you know but when i listen to like
female artists and i see the way
you know females react to their
you know what they're putting out there
i think it's like a dope thing to like
see it's like oh they feel it makes them
feel good like yeah because because i'm
like i already think i i know it's good
you know i know it's good and and you
know especially the songs like uh
like you're saying like um like the
misery business and you know these
lyrics that she's talking about like
these hardships these breakups you know
dealing with these certain things in her
life that you know
majority females can connect with but
also like you know me being a man and
being able to sit there and listen and
go that's [ __ ] dope yeah you know
what i mean so like that's why
you know the the a lot of the female
artists that you like sent me of like
who you like i get it you know what i
mean i get it yeah because it's like oh
they they push out like this and
empowerment in an authentic way and i
used to be ashamed of like half of the
people like i used to be so ashamed of
being into half the people on that list
yeah yeah because i went through this
weird
phase in like high school where i wanted
to turn away from anything that was
remotely girly anything remotely
feminine and so i love the pussycat
dolls i love damn
oh it's so good i listened to that [ __ ]
today like if i'm doing it have you ever
listened
i think he opens the song with a verse
or whatever yeah but that [ __ ]
slaps and it's so funny the vanity cane
yeah like all these bands
love them but i used to pretend like i
wasn't into them the only time i felt
like it was socially acceptable for me
to show that i [ __ ] with these songs or
these bands were like was when i was
dancing and someone else made
choreography
okay like
those bands may
made me feel extremely feminine when i'm
dancing to those songs but on a
day-to-day basis i don't feel very
feminine as like you gotta just like i'm
i'm always very stoic i'm very
tomboy-ish am i stoic yes that that's a
great compliment yeah yeah yeah i only
know that because i you know mm-hmm i
just read up on stoicism yeah but
anytime every anyone asked me the
definition of stoicism i do not know it
and i was like it's vibe
you know when you've seen it always
reach out to casey i'm like
and then he shows you a picture
[Laughter]
no no because that is very interesting
you say that like you are very stoic
you know
but like uh
you know and
you with you having the only fans it
shows this other layer
to you you know what i mean it's just
like weird because i'm never like that
i'm always i know that's what i'm saying
like it's like but it's but it's cool
like it's cool that it's another layer
it's cool because it's a different
version of me though yeah like i don't
express very much because i don't feel
very feminine but though like listening
to songs from pizza dolls danny kane
like so do you have do you have you have
music playing when you're doing your
photo shoots to kind of get you in the
movie uh sometimes like because my
agency will set that up sometimes my
photographer will have like a playlist
yeah and that's dope but if i had like
uh
i i should really create my own playlist
for those photos yeah
because i have like a
like my favorite song back in the day
when i was a kid like too young to be
listening to this was i want to be bad
by willa ford do i know that one it's
like
a really like raunchy song for that time
william ford it's basically like uh her
talking about how like she wants to be
like this bad girl and i was like
willa willa yeah just will with the a
well
i said
william
law it's just willa ford
yeah she's i think a canadian singer
okay
she had one really big hit it was i want
to be bad and it was just such a like a
was she around the time of like uh
like a natasha bettingfield i think a
little before just a little before
natasha benningfield is the builder
[Music]
right yeah okay unwritten that was the
theme song to like laguna hills or
something yep
uh what else pocket full of sunshine oh
yep joe so you brought up like danny
kane i remember uh being in high school
and like you know did you watch the show
did i watch the show did i watch making
the van of course
used to
torture people those shows would crack
me the [ __ ] like that like that kind of
reality tv was funny to me that's what i
wish they still had to this day yes like
these like thugged out sing-offs between
the guys they were singing boys to men
they were acting like hard in the
corners and they come together for this
like glee moment where they're all yes
and then they're all like yeah but i
love how diddy would go hard on all
those guys like i remember what was the
what was the boy group's name uh
day 26 is that what their name was yeah
it was something weird
horrible name and then uh one guy his
name was donnie donnie the white dude
yeah he got it yeah
yeah he got a solo career
is it still killing it i saw listen to
that song uh exclusive that was their
like those are yup now they were working
up to all season long so funny i forgot
about that dude donny
because yeah he didn't actually make the
group yeah i think they just like his
swagger and his style and they're like
we can do something typing donnie making
where's donnie now yeah that dude right
there
no no go to that one [ __ ] picture
yeah
donnie was jersey shore before before it
was jersey shore like
i don't even think he's from jersey i
wonder what he's doing i don't know what
he's oh that's his uh [ __ ] what
what is he doing i hope he's doing good
what's he go to now
donnie clang donny clark
yeah i remember i remember that dude
that white boy mm-hmm he could sing he
could get down he could sing and he was
the one who dated uh the girl aubrey
o'day from he dated aubry yeah i
remember there were a few girls from
david aubry's the blonde blue-eyed girl
she's banging she is very pretty
what do you say she does a lot of
reality tv stuff she does yeah see that
was see that was a period of time where
like reality tv was like that was speak
reality tv because then you had run's
house yeah like i [ __ ] with that [ __ ]
i liked run's house i like all the
dating shows the original while in out
original wildling out is so original
they had cat williams
they had [ __ ] afian crockett dion
cole they had all the [ __ ] bangers
on there they had so many [ __ ] these
are all people who still work to this
day exactly it's like it really does
hold up the tested time yeah i mean it's
still killing it today too which is
[ __ ] crazy but that was a but like
when i think about that time
like that's when i was in like the
heaviness of like like cheerleading was
my [ __ ]
life you know just working towards
daytime
what'd you say working towards daytona
yeah
she's you know she's seen cheer how many
of you guys one and two watches i've i'm
all caught up on both seasons are you
serious i love cheering so did you know
tvcc that's where i used to cheer for
real that's where i'm alumni
yeah
i'm going out there to visit them can i
come
so you can see the world of julie that'd
be funny it's i mean it's in the
smallest town in the [ __ ] world but
but yeah that's what yeah that's where i
used to cheer
yeah
that's that's my [ __ ] yeah
y'all really didn't watch it yeah no i
[ __ ] yeah you know it's it's so funny
thinking about that period of time in my
life because like
i don't know cheerleading like no one
really looked at it as like pretty much
anything like no like no one cared even
though like we had like the most titles
on campus even though you guys were the
[ __ ] within that world like no one else
outside that world no one else had no
one gave a [ __ ] there was time we would
do like these pep rallies or anything
like that and we'd go out there and
there'd be people in the crowd that gave
us zero shits about the [ __ ] cheers
and we'd be doing the most badass [ __ ]
yeah because you've seen me yeah
absolutely you know uh the
uh navarro college is going on tour now
to do what cheer kind of like uh they're
going to city the city doing their
routine oh really yeah they're on tour
now oh wow
i was like huh that's interesting yes
yeah i don't know how that
i don't know how that works hey good for
them hey capitalize i guess yeah [ __ ]
do that you know go on
tour to do cheerleading routines well
because you know actually it makes sense
because if so many people are watching
the show
then it's actually then people are
actually like thinking it's like dope
because like honestly when we go out and
do these these
uh when we go out and do competitions
like we do them
like in arenas not like a re sorry not
like arenas but like uh
these big like uh convention centers
yeah where's [ __ ] thousands and
thousands of people so it's like it
makes sense but like but that's just in
that world that's how like small it is
but like when you're in it it's like the
biggest thing but like all that music
like all these artists that you had sent
me
that's like
what like makes me think of like my time
in cheerleading you know what i mean
like all that stuff was heavily played
that's what all the girls were like
listening to so like i enjoyed it too
but but also when i think back
i already loved like a lot of like
female artists like janet jackson
is [ __ ] like
she's still in my [ __ ] top five yeah
i was listening to all for you literally
i was listening to that last night
dude i'm loving this episode [ __ ]
everybody [ __ ] everybody who are your
favorite female artists if you had like
uh if i had to like break it down yeah
uh i [ __ ] with dolly parton dolly
parton i'm [ __ ] with her uh i [ __ ]
with uh um i [ __ ] with beyonce
i do i actually actually like beyonce i
like whitney houston love janet jackson
um
[ __ ] [ __ ] um
let me think of everything i'm like
drawing a blank i actually i actually
didn't mind some of miley cyrus's stuff
miley cyrus
had such good songs for like a disney
star yeah and i didn't realize that
there were quality songs till i got
older because i think every time i heard
a
someone singing a song on disney i just
put it under the
category of oh this is a disney song
it's not like real
songs it's like songs made for the
disney channel yep but the climb [ __ ]
bomb the climb was
the [ __ ] oh [ __ ] uh uh jimmy lovato
demi lovato she [ __ ] with her yes i
mean
little different now she's a little
different now if uh
a little bit y'all been looking at the
news and stuff on demi lovato the voice
music amazing amazing i think i [ __ ]
with her heavy she's got dope [ __ ]
um
obviously ariana grande mariah [ __ ]
with mariah carey yes heavy
there was one the album emancipation of
mimi oh my god wait what is that uh
no no wait wait wait wait hold on
what was can you type in
sorry my mind your blade because i was
trying to think of something you said
something that then i missed it
type of mariah carey uh discography
let me see
um
[Music]
shut up okay
there's a specific
god she has such a what's the wonderful
so wait which one had uh like look
obsessed
was it the one the the memoirs um
which one had obsessed obsessed i loved
obsessed why are you so awesome she was
playing eminem in the [ __ ] music
video i know that was yeah
i know and then he came back pretty hard
he came back hard he came back really
hard he had a recording that i don't
think she knew was yeah he gave out uh
real yeah
he's very aggressive very good very good
very aggressive but also like what do
you expect if you're gonna
was it all that oh eminem oh so i was
right
that's on that album yes
that album's fire and obviously the uh
uh the emancipation
um that one that one's got like shake it
off
shake it off i gotta shake it off
cause i love it
that [ __ ] this album
slaps we belong together yeah oh we
belong together
get the [ __ ]
out of here
what that song alone
if you made that one song and nothing
else in your career you've made it you
we
that song hits so [ __ ] hard it's it's
so [ __ ]
good and it's one of those songs where
when i meet someone younger and they
know something like that like a song
like that i know they were raised yeah i
know they were raised
like musically your parents your
brothers your sister your uncles your
aunts like they put you on some good
[ __ ] yeah i'm loving this episode i
listen i don't know anyone else yeah
that i can talk to with
yeah cause i'm like man i like i'm like
when can i [ __ ] talk about mariah
cause you've been waiting and then i was
like cat and then a [ __ ] light bulb
went off in my [ __ ] head yeah ain't
that right meatball
i'll talk about mariah carey all you
want yeah and fantasy her og stuff yeah
fantasy [ __ ] slaps i remember that
scene in russia i forgot what that song
was like when you go wrong
yeah
[ __ ]
you know she looks like i looked her up
i would say two years ago
i remember seeing that photo like damn
she grew up really well look at this
beautiful lady
the girl who played too young
yeah
uh and then put rush hour yeah yeah
go to
now
is that the one no
that might be her uh that looks
different from the photo i saw but yeah
still i don't know pretty much the
correct photo
you know what she kind of looks like in
the middle in that middle photo right
there in the trio she looks like
oh sorry no because you know how little
kim had uh surgery done recently she
looks like that
she does
they have the same surgeon that is fair
yes good for them
wait
but i don't i think it's the one on the
right the far right and the farmer that
could be let's see her soo young rush
hour ig
that'll that'll let us know everything
do we even remember what her like real
name is that i know i feel bad helpful
because i don't know her name either no
no
that might be it
that i guess that's her yeah
wow wow
okay so young okay so yeah where'd that
booty come from girl
you know where it came from yeah i know
that's fair that's right that's fair
good for you good good for sue young
yeah but yeah she was singing that song
and rush hour in the in the
uh [ __ ] love rush hour oh my gosh i
love that [ __ ] movie
yeah uh
man
this is [ __ ] so then you mentioned
like
which i haven't
you know i haven't necessarily listened
to yet
there was someone on there hold on let
me look at this list
hold on
where's catine
you have me under your phone as kateen
yes cute
i love it
are you listening to the pretty reckless
yeah is that the girl from uh uh gossip
girl yeah gossip girl used to be in i
saw her live really yep i saw her live
back in like 2012. yeah taylor momsen
yep love her yeah she's a beast i used
to watch her on gossip girl and i
remember she left the show to pursue
music and i didn't know what type of
music she made
uh when i looked into it i was like oh
this is very different from the gospel
girl is intense gossip girl was right
kind of i think like an og euphoria
no i would say it's more like uh toned
down sex in the city uh old school
euphoria is more like degrassi or skins
degrassi was like degrassi was like og
euphoria okay listen i watched an
episode of euphoria for the first time
ever i've never seen it season never
i've never seen it no it was just my
buddy was showing me yeah like a random
episode he was like he's like to get a
gist of it let me show you this episode
yeah and i was this was last night and i
watched the episode what the [ __ ] was it
where zendaya was like going off on
everyone no it was where she was like uh
she they were at a party and she was
doing drugs
and then there was a
girl
the blonde girl was having sex with a
dude in the bathroom and then his
ex-girlfriend was oh yeah knocking on
the door yeah right and then that dude
gets beat up at the end of the i'm like
what the [ __ ]
is this
we didn't have anything that intense no
back in the day intense they weren't
showing titties on degrassi
no you're were they no i'm not cause
that girl that girl's titties was out
the girl yeah
actually if you if you go to a different
episode there's a lot of dicks in there
too like they show a lot of penis
a lot of them let me tell you this
girl's titties very big very nice
titties
how do you know what i'm talking about
sure do
of course casey does
he's like don't ask me he's like what is
going on
i love that show though you like that
show you can get into that i like [ __ ]
like that if i'm being completely honest
i think i've said it before i tend to
watch a lot of shows where there's
nudity yeah it tends to reel me in
because it gives me a more realistic
perspective of like yeah what was
happening yeah or like maybe i'm just
attracted to like the raunchy factor of
it but then i really like the story
lines afterwards so like i really like
spartacus yeah there was a lot of
[ __ ] in there game of thrones
euphoria i like shows like that yeah
like euphoria is really good
because zendaya is amazing she and you
know she was but like the i guess the
thing for me is maybe i just got to
watch more episodes really start from
the beginning to get a better foundation
of it but the thing was for me like
because i don't i don't mind that kind
of stuff like because i mean i watched
sons of anarchy and that was pretty like
like a pretty intense
show that i actually like really liked
but like with euphoria i guess for me it
was just like
and i guess it's because i'm old
i'm like man these kids are in high
school right you know what i mean like
this because that's the setting of it
like these kids are in high school that
is a really big
controversy behind the show now because
as the episodes
start to continue on this particular
season it gets more explicit it gets a
little crazier each and every time yeah
and people are like are you trying to
glorify this because they are at the end
of the day playing high school
adults here's my thing
my thing is what it is is this like
listen that [ __ ] goes down
in high school
that [ __ ] happens
totally [ __ ] happens but for me
i what my my high school experience was
not any of that like obviously i knew
that [ __ ] was going on that [ __ ] was
around and stuff like that but like for
me like i just didn't have that high
school experience so that's why it's
hard for me to like even connect with it
see i'm the opposite i did not have that
experience but i like watching it almost
because i had fomo when i was younger
and i always felt like i was missing out
on something because i was so sheltered
and so watching stuff like that like oh
is that what really happened behind the
scenes isn't that
like what high school was for certain
people but i don't think it was i think
like certain aspects of it yeah i think
yeah i knew people who had addiction
issues in high school i knew people were
having sex in high school but i don't
think it was that crazy yeah yeah i
don't know if it was yeah i yeah i don't
know if it was that quick yeah i was and
obviously like are they
are these like rich kids
uh no uh i believe it's it takes place
in southern california they're all kind
of like
different socioeconomic classes there's
some people who are richer than others
some people okay okay so so they have
everybody in the mix yeah okay then i
guess that you know that's fair too but
i guess just like yeah i was just like i
can't connect with this i was like i
don't [ __ ]
you know if i want to watch a show that
has like something to do with high
school
you know i mean my favorite [ __ ]
movie is this movie you know angus
you know but that i thought
[ __ ] you casey
dawson's creek
did its damn thing in its day though
you know
like
yeah i [ __ ] with that i [ __ ] with
dawson's creek it was you know a lot
more g-rated than uh but it's still
touched on
things but like i was like oh that's you
know my show was one tree hill oh i
remember that what was it chad chad
michael murray chad michael first names
yup hell yeah [ __ ] that guy up to now
he's right he is i know he's still
acting i saw a promotion for one of his
recent projects he was like the [ __ ]
heartthrob heartthrob autumn girl autumn
girls were
in love with chad michael murray who was
the girl on the show um
ah [ __ ] uh her name was brooke sophia
bush sophia bush yeah i guess
the girl that he ended up marrying in
real life and then they divorced like
are they married in real life what
should she look like they were for a
while and then they got divorced because
he went and recorded the movie house of
wax and cheated on her with paris hilton
oh
yeah let me see i'm telling you i know a
lot of this
she's gorgeous yeah she's beautiful
she's still acting as well
she's still acting as well yeah
and then chad michael murray's just chad
michael murray is also acting as well
let's let's see his ig let's see what
time i can vary up on ig
chad michael murray just looks like like
he was like the [ __ ] he was a
heartthrob he was so good looking dude
he was like it yeah he was like the guy
oh okay
yeah there it is
look at that heartthrob oh my god i just
remember every girl talking about yep
chad michael murray every girl that i
cheered with and some of the dudes that
i cheered with were all talking about
chad michael murray
it was like chad michael murray then
shortly after was channing tatum that
was like yeah lineup of guys
yeah
ryan reynolds his first his first right
i think
chad what is his name channing tatum
i think his first
ch chad yeah his first role was uh i
think coach carter coach carter you ever
see coach carter yeah i love that movie
was that his first one
or wasn't she yeah that's what i thought
it was because i remember
reading a article where amanda bynes
says that they were going through like
audition stuff because he was a model
before she she
vouched for him yeah she was like no we
this is the guy yeah
what's his catalog
oh god magic mike
magic mike had the opposite effect on me
i remember all of my girlfriends being
super entertaining to him all those guys
in there but the moment i see a man
shake his ass on stage it's like you're
not sexual in life you know what's so
weird like i don't imagine like
okay let me know this this is fair and i
hope this doesn't offend anybody or you
know since we on a path of like
you know
people wanting to you know come at me
yeah magic mike do you think that's for
like older women
i think it's for older women and gay men
i don't think it's for younger women
it's just like not the thing that i
would imagine yeah like
a younger generation of women liking
that yeah i i don't know too many people
who watched it who were my age or
younger who were like oh chain team i'm
so hot in this
like that that wasn't the thing yeah
because it's like what do you would like
i don't imagine like
i don't know younger women getting a
kick out of that i think
she's the man and dear john were the two
movies for the younger women yeah
because it's like that's like
because that's like a [ __ ] you know
like rom-com or you know what it is
because it's more realistic
yeah you think that you think that's
what it is for like women like that
that's realistic like oh that that could
really [ __ ] happen like magic mike no
no nothing i'm talking about like the
like that she's the man like he's the
man like you look at that character he
played
as a woman and you're like oh that's
more realistic i think it's more
realistic for a girl who's maybe like
under the age of 20
than like meeting a stripper and then
like falling in love with him yeah he's
trying to like get a loan from a bank
for a furniture company
like i think that's like breaking the
[ __ ] down like going to a private school
where you're like you're pretending to
be a guy yeah to play soccer with this
really hot dude against your
ex-boyfriend's team like it's more
realistic that's more realistic
yes who wants to change his life yeah
cause that's like fantasy yeah
you know or it's just like so far
removed age-wise like
i remember when i met stevie like i
thought he was like an adult granted i
was already like 23 but in my head like
that's an adult like i don't [ __ ] with
people like that because like he's just
like
mentally on another level like that's
not for me
like the
like the fiasco of the rom-com is more
my
or was it the proposal
was the proposal with uh ryan
reynolds and sandra bullock yeah
the one you know one of my uh more
recent i really loved uh crazy stupid
love oh crazy stupid love is so good
ryan gosling
julian moore
is such a heartthrob i know have you
seen him like no no no like he is a
silver fox really i think he's so
handsome really i think he's so [ __ ]
happy the older he gets
the more like i think he's never been
hotter yeah yeah
that oh wow
look at him
what wow he looks great i would let this
man ruin my life look at him that's so
funny he's silver fox he
he looks better do you think he looks
better like as a silver fox than like
yes and i also know he's funny because i
like his career so that's even more
attractive
but like
such a like he's so hot to me yeah like
as an older man dude rom-coms had me and
my [ __ ] emotions what was your
favorite rom-com oh the great crazy
stupid looks
like that's like your number one yeah uh
i really like that one but like there's
just something about them because like
you know
i'm such a lover boy you are a lover boy
that's what i love you're very sensitive
you like
big [ __ ] time like you're like a big
softy yeah like especially like when i
[ __ ] you casey
when i when i love
rocking it and when i think about like
some of these like female songs like
you know
i think i would listen to him like also
to like
you know find my way to like connect
with a girl like a dope way yeah you
know and
a lot of times it didn't work you know
yeah you know a lot of times i would say
you know it was i'd say probably a 100
percent fail
you know
you got to put in you know what they say
what's the opposite of 100 success rate
100 percent
unsuccessful yeah failure rate yes okay
100 failure rate you know because what
it was with me is i was too
not that i was too soft as much as i was
just like
i i wasn't realistic
it's like no one loves
that [ __ ] way you know what i mean
yeah and which is fair you know what i
mean i had to like level it out and like
be like oh like hey yeah like you don't
have to be so [ __ ] puppy dog like
you know saying dumb lines like oh your
eyes are as beautiful as the stars or
something like that that's so sweet i
know wait
i know i mean i'm not saying i would say
that
yes you did i know right
we've all used it right fellas
yeah
[Laughter]
so when you edit that when you add more
voices
make it like this yeah multiply it yeah
multiply it at a last track from one
other bunch of dudes that are like yeah
no but yeah that's how i was with uh
you know a lot of [ __ ] all right so now
we're at a portion where i do these
rapid questions okay um
favorite band paramore paramore okay
favorite uh
solo artist
uh solo artist as of right now i would
say maggie lindemann
who's that she's kind of like a new
generation of like all emo girl she is
like one of those girls who were like
haley walks so she could run wait
maggie
lindenman
she has this new song out called she
knows it and the premise of the song is
like
go to her
i have a crush on a girl who has a
boyfriend
really and she's dope she's dope she
makes great music really knife under my
pillow is great
has she worked with like travis barker
and stuff yeah she was in that movie
with machine gun kelly travis barker
that like uh short film that they worked
on really yeah yo i think a guy
oh
i think i know her manager yeah yeah
a guy that's from back home in arizona
yeah yeah oh that's joke yeah i know her
manager but yeah she's [ __ ] dope oh i
gotta get her on there i'm gonna put
that she's like one of the like
up-and-coming artists who is having like
this resurgence of like alt music right
now oh really yeah like she plays with a
band and everything oh i'm definitely
i'll definitely check her out all right
uh favorite concert favorite concert um
[Music]
my new mentor
just because i was like that
was a special place in my heart
that's what
favorite album
favorite album um
i don't know if i have like a favorite
album i will say like my favorite album
as of recently was olivia rodrigo's most
recent one
is reminiscent of uh some taylor swift
[ __ ] okay yeah it's great real good like
sap sappy like
slow like it's for the sensitive girls
you know yeah yeah there you go yeah
like high school
heartbreak
album it's olivia okay yeah i gotta
check her stuff out uh then uh now we do
we close it out with a playlist yeah so
basically the playlist is like a
soundtrack to the episode yeah um it
could be you could put up stuff we
talked about or whatever you feel the
vibe is or whatever and uh we do like 10
to 12 songs and i'll start it off i'll
go with um
i'll go with uh
damn
i'll go with mariah carey we belong to
guerra together
i would go
paramore crazy girls
okay
i'll actually do another paramore one uh
for uh
for a pessimist i'm pretty optimistic ah
that's one of my yeah that's a good song
uh
who else i'm gonna do pussycat dolls uh
buttons okay
you have to do featuring snoop dogg
yes
uh i'll another one with a five minute
dance break yeah i'll do
[Music]
i'll do janet jackson
uh
dang somebody we could go with right
janet um what's in your heart right now
well let's do all for you offer use a
good one
uh i'm gonna go maggie lindemann she
knows
i'll go whitney houston
let's go whitney houston uh
we'll go dance with somebody
oh that's dope yeah
i'm gonna do day 26 exclusive
i don't know where any of those men are
i think one of them ended up on love and
hip-hop for a short amount of time with
the fact that you added
oh the song is called the song is called
exclusive
it's a dope song to this day
anything donnie clang has made in the
last 10 years
hopefully hopefully it's good uh let's
go jojo like that
let's have another jojo one just because
it's her uh
baby it's you
good one
um
let's go beyonce uh
what was on my list let's see
what beyonce do i want to do
do beyonce
come on what's that [ __ ] song i
really like briar
[ __ ] slaps hard
oh yeah yeah let's do beyonce formation
formation is a good one
uh let's go i know we didn't talk about
them but let's go tegan and sarah
walking with hey
all right i respect all that
how many we got
walking with a ghost
you know that one
how many we got
i think we got an album yeah we got a
full album
we have a now 26.
all right
[Laughter]
no [ __ ] that i don't put it up there
let's top it off with it we're going to
top it off with ben miller
with beneath my wings
the only song that really matters if you
hear any of these songs
that's the one well
cat that's the episode yo check out cats
only fans uh subscribe to that [ __ ] i
don't know is that weird to like tell
people to no like
i know where you're coming from because
i feel weird saying that too so i'm just
like hey go to my instagram and then uh
hit that link if you want to see other
[ __ ] yeah and then uh i'll be on tour
february at the end of this month
february 22 25th and 26th i'll be in
kansas city missouri at the comedy club
of kansas city march 10th through the
12th i'll be in springfield missouri at
the blue room comedy club and then april
8th
and april 9th i'll be in salt lake city
at wise guys comedy club and then in may
hometown i'm coming through get those
[ __ ] tickets may 12th i'll be at
stand up live in phoenix boom
yeah and that's our episode thanks for
having me all right thanks for coming on
hell yeah
you